he's the general behind a coup that's
led to hundreds of deaths
but in indonesia minar flying received a
vips welcome
his journey to an emergency summit to
discuss the crisis
sparked by myanmar's military beginning
with a red
carpet while covid put pay to handshakes
furious protesters believed he should
have been greeted
with handcuffs how you can discuss with
the person
who doing kudeta and
until now he didn't stop any any murder
in the myanmar
how can you discuss with the murderer
security was tight ahead of the meeting
of southeast asian leaders
the aim today to try to persuade the
general to end the killings
and begin a path to peace but the very
decision to invite him
sparked accusations of helping to
legitimize an illegal regime
junta forces have killed more than 700
people in myanmar since february's coup
the ongoing crackdowns triggered
economic social and political turmoil
leaving neighbours fearing a flood of
refugees and the prospect of a failed
state on their doorstep today's message
the violence must stop now process
dialogue
young inclusive
politics
[Music]
asean so this is the crucial test for
asean and myanmar
will the agreements made here and the
killing
at home i'm not sure how it will stop
immediately
i do think what we have is a beginning
of a commitment
but of course for that commitment to be
fulfilled
uh we need to see what kind of uh
framework and plan
that asean will put forward and how we
can negotiate
those framework as soon as possible uh
with the military regime
and myanmar doesn't have time to lose
deeply divided this country is a
breaking point
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok